closet attics six of our northern cities  had fallen in a coordinated attack their  leader fights alongside of which  crush these murderers your majesty every  family must contribute one man to fight  your war hero you've already made many  great sacrifices  my father cannot fight so I will take  his place the northern invaders will  kill her if I expose her power all  people will kill her when we take the  Imperial City I will take revenge for my  father what is your name soldier  ha Joon commander so no Quadro you will  now take the oath of the warrior  release  [Music]  [Music]  died pretending to be something you're  not  yet here I stand proof that there is a  place for people like us  a girl threatens our plants  a warrior  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you